I've lived in the public eye
and I really believe a lot of what they
said Diva Theory O'Brien I said to her
once doesn't this bother you and she
said I expected this Ben Affleck getting
candid about Fame
specifically how it impacts his fiance
Jennifer Lopez the Oscar winner opens up
in Jen's documentary halftime dropping
June 14th on Netflix
it's a short but powerful moment that
dropped in the trailer on Wednesday I
said to her once doesn't this bother you
and she said I expected this the
documentary is centered on Jen preparing
for the 2020 Super Bowl halftime show I
want something real
do this not for an award
do this to connect with people and make
them feel things because I want to feel
something feel something oh we sure felt
something and E.T was with Jen just days
leading up to the big moment we're gonna
try to give the best Super Bowl show
ever you know J.Lo's documentary also
covers the highs and lows of her work in
hustlers
but it's like robbing the bank except
you got the keys
are you in not only did the movie
generate Oscars buzz but Jen did too for
her performance as a stripper named
Ramona what do you make of all the buzz
I mean it's it's incredible you know you
you sign on to these movies you give it
your all you do all you can you know
learning the pole dancing the emotional
journey of what these girls go through
um me playing a character like I've
never played up a real badass here a
real bad girl Kessler's first review is
Jennifer Lopez disaster worthy it was
hard I just had a very low self-esteem
halftime will also look at the
multi-hyphenates long career from her
days in the Bronx to Hollywood royalty
my whole life I've been battling to be
heard to be seen to be taken seriously
one thing that's changed since the
documentary was shot Jen's love life
while filming she was engaged to Alex
Rodriguez
I mean we've been having a lot of fun
and I've been enjoying just spending
time with her our kids her kids and we
learn we have a lot of fun for each
other but they broke things off in 2021
and now Jen is one half of benefit 2.0
I've heard you say so many times that
you are a hopeless romantic and you
still believe in love you believe in
marriage so like cat you still believe
in all of those absolutely why wouldn't
I
and finally has been seeing the movie
yet you brought your fella with you
tonight he's seen it yeah yeah he this
is just a good date man it's a great
date night we're super happy
um what can I tell you we're just having
a good time I would be remiss if I
didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
was very big I didn't really realize how
big
it didn't take long for Ben to pop the
question again just over a year after
rekindling their Romance
[Music]
and while we stay tuned for any wedding
updates we'll have half time to look
forward to
[Music]